our doctor Tara Narula is here with how
infectious the disease actually is and
how it affects the human body it's our
good morning good morning what do we
actually know about how the virus is
spread so what we know about kovat 19:00
is based on what we know about how other
corona viruses are spread which is
person-to-person contact by droplet so
if I cough or sneeze those droplets can
travel up to six feet and enter your
mouth or your nose or your lungs another
way is if I cough or sneeze and it lands
on a surface or an object and then you
touch that same object or surface and
touch your face
the virus can enter that way you know we
do think that as I said the spread is
confined to about six feet that it's not
really airborne like some diseases like
measles are for example so that's why
people are concerned with the masks what
are some of the signs and symptoms so
signs and symptoms fever cough shortness
of breath in some cases people can have
headache or even diarrhea muscle aches
sore throat runny nose congestion it's
easy to work yourself up I was in the
gym working out in another in LA over
the weekend somebody starts coughing you
look over them you're on a plane so he
starts coughing and sneezing how do we
put this in perspective terror about how
worried we should be and when to really
get worried
I think what everybody is saying is that
we need to be prepared and not panicked
right that's what easier said than done
it is easier said than done but when you
look at what we know from China eighty
percent of those cases were mild they
had mild symptoms only about 14% were
severe and even less were critical
the death rate that we have calculated
at this point is about two percent
although because there's probably so
many more cases than we've detected it's
probably even lower so in the grand
scheme of things for most people if they
get it it will end up being a mild just
when it can be treated it can be treated
if you get it it can be treated well
treat it with supportive care right we
don't have any sort of antiviral that's
designated there's no recs yeah yeah
there's no because it when does it
become deadly right so the issue with
koban 19 is that this virus can affect
the lower tract of your airway so can
enter those cells that line your
respiratory tract in the lung
and there it can start to replicate and
damage those cells what happens after
that point is your immune system
launches a response to try to clean up
and repair the problem is in some people
that immune system response is so
overwhelming it's not in check and that
basically floods the lungs with
inflammatory mediators and cellular
debris and you also have leakiness of
the blood vessels so essentially the
lungs start to drown and that's in a
situation that can become a severe
pneumonia the pneumonia can then
progress to what we call sepsis where
you can have a drop of blood pressure
and multi organ failure and that's how
it really causes death
you know the lungs are where we exchange
oxygen and carbon dioxide so if your
lungs are full of fluid and debris in
the cellular material you cannot get
oxygenated blood into your cells to the
rest of your body that's how it becomes
severe all right dr. Tara Tara no rule
or name hasn't changed thank you thank
you very much